ANDREW URMAN: Hi, everyone.
My name's Andrew.
I work on the Developer
Relations Team at Nest Labs.
Just a quick show of hands,
who's heard of Nest so far?
All right.
That's great.
For those who haven't, we
kind of have a simple mission.
And what we want to
do is build a home
that's thoughtful-- one that can
think for you, react for you;
something that doesn't involve
a lot of set up, process,
or configuration.
And build products
that people love,
products, typically,
that haven't
seen innovation in years.
And one of the products
we started out with
hadn't seen innovation in
about 30 or almost 50 years,
actually.
And it was the first-generation
Nest Learning Thermostat.
And the idea was the
thermostat, packed
with a bunch of onboard
sensors, could learn for you,
could learn the
schedule for you,
and take automatic action to
lower the set point for you
and save energy.
We added features
like Auto Away,
which could detect if
you're home or not,
to further save energy.
We then expanded to the
Nest Protect, a device that
could alert you to smoke
or carbon monoxide danger,
and specifically,
what room it's in.
And then just recently
launched the Nest Cam,
a camera that you can
check in from anywhere
just about any time.
But that wasn't just it.
We want to build
a thoughtful home.
What that means
is we didn't want
to have another remote to
control, an app to open,
or even a hub to plug in.
What we really
believe is devices
should be able to speak to
each other, locally, as well
as devices outside the
home, like cars and phones,
so they can inform the home
to make better decisions.
You can see this today
with our own products.
For example, if the Nest
Protect senses carbon monoxide,
the thermostat can automatically
shut off the heat furnace,
which is typically the source.
And if you have
a Nest Cam, it'll
automatically start
recording a video
and save it, regardless of
if you have service or not.
That really isn't it.
What we really wanted is
a home that could think,
one that didn't respond
to just certain things.
So we built what we
like to call Nest Sense.
It's an intelligence
layer available to users
and developers.
And it can take all
sorts of information
and make better decisions.
This is the part of the smart
home that really sets us apart.
This is the hardest part.
It's not just about triggers
or anything like that.
So some examples
are Home and Away,
which is our whole home
occupancy model, determining
if anyone's home or not.
ETA, which is-- we kind of
saw an example of a slide
ago-- where a car can tell the
home exactly when someone's
going to be there, and
line up the set points
at the exact perfect time.
And Energy Rush Hour, which
is our type of energy demand
response.
If you don't know what that is,
it helps utilities shift load,
and we also help
users save money.
So we built this
for our products,
but we didn't want
it to stop there.
We also wanted to
work with developers.
About a year and a half
ago, we launched the Work
with Nest platform.
It's currently about
14,000 developers,
building anything from--
we've seen washing machines
to connected pet feeders,
like you saw the other day.
All sorts of devices.
It's been a lot of fun to
see what people come up with.
It's been very popular.
Right now, one in
every eight Nest homes
has a Work with Nest
developer in it.
And I think the popularity
is due to us working
with developers to figure
out great features, not just
integrations.
We don't want to
connect devices just
for the sake of connecting them.
We want things to happen
in a great way that's
easy for a user.
And, of course, it's
almost impossible
to talk about the connected
home without mentioning privacy.
And at Nest, we really
believe in user transparency.
So as developers--
keep this in mind--
when you're building Works
with Nest connection,
you have to explain to a
user in very plain terms
exactly what piece of
data you're asking for,
and give a reason for it.
Unfortunately, as
developers, if you're
trying to ask for a piece of
data without a clear use case,
we won't allow that.
Users must know what's
going on with their data.
And we're fully
focused on the home.
It's not a research
topic for us.
It's not a testing
the waters type deal.
We're not seeing how
it's playing out.
We're all obsessed
with the home.
We feel when it doesn't work.
We know when things happen,
and should happen differently.
And we love working
with developers
who feel the same way.
And we love showing
them off too.
We recently launched a
Works with Nest catalog.
It's a place online
where developers
can submit their
integrations to this portal,
and users can come in
and browse by device,
and see what else is compatible.
And it doesn't
matter if you're one
of the biggest
companies in the world
or just a single
developer at home.
But we've also built
some great tools,
and this one actually
has a funny backstory.
We heard horror stories
of developers lighting
paper towels on fire to test
their carbon monoxide sensor
and smoke sensor.
So I said, it's about
time to build a simulator.
It runs as a Chrome app.
It runs fully as a Chrome app.
And it can simulate just about
any readable field in the API.
And you can also, actually,
respond to changes, too.
So if you make a
change into the API,
the simulator will
update in real time.
What's also great
about the simulator
is you can test all
sorts of home scenarios.
So you don't have to go out and
buy 20 thermostats, and 20 Nest
Cams, and devices.
In the simulator,
you can simulate
two different locations with
all sorts of different devices
to really test what
you've been building.
But let's take a quick look at
what a typical response would
look like.
This is from our
newly-released Nest Cam API.
You can see it's formatted
in very basic JSON, very
standard structure,
key value pairings.
Get really interesting
information
like the name, which is typical.
You can tell if it's
streaming or not.
And probably the
most important one
is if you see this
last event bucket here,
that is real-time notifications
on motion or sound.
So as a developer, you can now
hook into the Nest Cam's motion
and sound capability
and get responses.
If the user happens to
have Nest Aware, which
is the subscription
model, then you
can get image snapshots
and GIFs of events,
and surface them
in your interfaces.
But the foundation was
important for the API.
So we built it on a fully
cross-platform ideology.
And Android is great.
We all love Android,
but for the smart home
to really be realized, it has
to be fully cross-platform.
We have Windows
Phone integrations
that we've seen people
make, and, of course, iOS.
Everything is RESTful.
Just about all your
calls, bulk of it
will be done using
HTTP GET and PUT,
some POST here now and then.
And, of course, like you
saw, everything's in JSON.
It's all encrypted.
It's all over HTTPS.
Someone actually
asked to not have
that for some reason,
which I thought was insane.
And all authentication
is done using OAuth2.
And we use these technologies
because they're very simple.
There's widespread
documentation for them.
There's communities full of
developers helping people out.
And you can get started
almost immediately.
Actually, we've seen people
launch integrations in 10 days,
and I've seen developers
get started in 20 minutes.
But let's say you've
signed up, you've
downloaded your simulator,
you understand what JSON is,
and now you want to get started.
We've built three
connection methods for you.
A Firebase and REST
Streaming, which are realtime,
and, of course,
your typical REST.
We almost always push
developers to do realtime.
There's really no good reason
to not do realtime anymore,
especially when it comes to IoT.
People have UX and UI that
they need to keep in date.
Users really know when
that's not perfect.
And it would be weird
to have a device trigger
something 10 minutes after
the actual event happened.
There was actually some good
talks about Firebase here,
and there will be one later,
as well, on the Android.
But let's take a typical
look at some architectures
that we typically see.
Here, Firebase is
great for mobile.
It has awesome libraries for
just about every platform.
And where it really excels is
in the type of architectures
where there are no
middle-ground servers.
So these devices are
holding their own databases,
or they're holding their
own source of truth.
And using Firebase, you can
use the asynchronous nature
of the streams to make
all calls, in and out,
in that single stream.
And we'll update you
once things change.
Firebase has actually been
pretty popular lately.
I've seen a lot used
in web browsers.
Like I mentioned,
Raspberry Pi has been huge.
There's a lot of Raspberry
Pi Firebase examples.
But it's really good
for devices that
are powerful enough to hold
their own basic node server.
For the cloud type
of architectures,
we have REST Streaming,
which is a one-way get.
So information only flows from
the Nest cloud to your service.
And what's nice about
this is it provides
a really good
foundation to scale
architectures to thousands of
users, hundreds of thousands
of users hopefully, right?
And if you're a
developer managing
all sorts of different
devices, different connectivity
types, devices, or phones,
this kind of cloud architecture
is really ideal, because
now you have our device
as part of the Nest cloud, and
a realtime input into what's
going on there.
And, of course,
there's just sometimes
no substitute for your
garden variety REST.
Information only
comes when asked for.
You asked, what's the
temperature today?
And it is 65.
The only problem with
this is it's not realtime.
You have to constantly
ask for updates.
It's not a great
user experience,
but it really does
have its place.
I personally use this constantly
when prototyping or debugging.
I use it a lot when testing.
I can use it quickly
to make a call
and see if it succeeded or not.
And the other day, I
was just testing around
and I messed up the URL path
in the API, which is arguably
the easiest part of the API.
But really put it all together,
this is what it looks like.
You have your Nest devices
talking to each other
and talking to the Nest service,
as well as communicating back
with the mobile app.
Connected all through the cloud
API to a developer service,
or like we saw earlier
with Firebase, a phone.
And this is a good start.
It's where we are today.
But it's not where
we wanted to be.
And that's when we decided
to come up with Nest Weave.
And what Nest Weave
is is a whole new way
to connect connected devices.
And we built Nest Weave
out of frustration
about what we saw out there.
Nothing else provided a
local, direct device-device
communication,
which is critical.
If a device is connected
directly to each other,
things can work
without the internet.
And the home needs to
work without the internet.
If your cable goes down,
everything should still work.
Weave is an application layer,
purely an application layer,
which means it can run over
different network types.
We're targeting a low power
mesh network called Thread.
It launched, and it will quickly
expand to Wi-Fi and local land
devices, as well.
It runs all over IPv6,
which means that we'll now
have a comprehensive solution
for just about every scenario
out there.
Where Nest Weave really excels
right now is with low power
battery-constrained devices with
very small hardware footprints.
Keeps cost down.
Typically, these devices
can't last on battery
on your normal Wi-Fi
connection for more than five
to six months.
But now with Nest Weave,
with your low power mode,
you can have a battery device
last for up to five years.
And it's secure.
Regardless of if
you're connecting
a Thread device
to a Wi-Fi device,
or low power to full power, it
provides end-to-end security.
Every message is
encrypted from the host
to wherever it's going.
There is no snooping.
There is no
man-in-the-middle attack.
The full message is encrypted.
Every device should
be encrypted.
In fact, we just had someone
argue that oh, a light bulb
doesn't need to be that secure.
But it absolutely does.
It provides weak points.
So everything is
absolutely secure.
And what Nest
Weave also provides
is a local access to
the Nest Services.
So here's what we saw before,
the typical architecture.
Again, it's a good start, but
it's reliant on the cloud.
It's reliant on two developer
services functioning.
And this is where we see
the typical Nest Weave
architecture looking like.
Devices are communicating
locally to each other,
but still back to
the Nest service.
And if you can see here, even
back to the developer service.
So you still don't have to
lose all that information.
Actually, our products
do this today.
Our Nest Protect, if it senses
smoke or carbon monoxide,
can alert the other Nest
Protects in the home,
using this Nest Weave network.
We use it today.
This is great.
It works without the internet.
Doesn't matter if
the router is on,
if the Wi-Fi is working,
if the power's on.
And it provided
great functionality
and we can't wait to
extend it to developers.
But reliable messaging
isn't the end of it.
Currently, there is
a semblance of IoT
where people are just
manufacturing these devices
that can be remote controlled.
I can turn on.
I can turn it off.
It is a good start.
Or they have this
assemblance of smart homes
that you have to build
complex rule systems for.
When condition A happens,
trigger action B.
The problem is it can be
very complex and confusing
for a standard user.
They now have to remember every
single rule that they made.
And if anything steps
outside of that rule,
they're kind of screwed.
Think of it this way.
If someone sets a rule up,
says when my phone leaves,
I want my lights to turn
off, the TV to turn off,
and the thermostat to cool down.
The problem is,
if someone leaves,
that will trigger--
even if someone's
sitting on the
couch watching TV--
it could provide a very
frustrating environment,
especially in your home.
Also, a lot of race
conditions happening.
Again, these users
now have to remember
every single rule they set up.
And we've seen horror stories
of people setting up a rule.
Turn off the power at five, and
then turn on the power at five.
So then what happens?
The way we see it, is we
want to expand Nest Sense.
And we're doing it in a way that
can adapt to the environment.
It can actually determine
what's going on.
We can use confidence levels to
say, I know if someone's home,
or I know no one's home.
And for the user, hopefully
that involves zero set-up.
Maybe a little option
here when they pair it,
but it should be very
easy and clear to a user,
and it can adapt to their lives.
And all this is just kind
of getting to the fact
that we need to really
understand what's happening,
not just send info
from rule A to rule B.
And we're starting to
expand this to developers.
Actually, no one's
seen this yet.
This actually has not
been released publicly.
But this is an example of what
our sensor API will look like.
Here, you can see an
example, a standard, again,
very basic JSON.
Looks just like our web API.
You have a light
that was turned off,
physically, and a motion
sensor that was just
activated for about a minute.
And let's go back to
that phone example.
A lot of people set up rules
that say, when I see motion,
turn a light on.
But in this scenario, someone
turned the switch physically
off.
Are we going to turn
the light back on?
That would be really weird.
So we're working on this
data API for developers
to start sharing
information, as well as
Nest sharing information back.
So all these inputs can now be
read locally by the Nest Sense
algorithms, and
developers can subscribe
to what's going on in the home.
And this is the hardest part,
by far, for developers to build.
And with this
solution, you don't
have to go build
your own algorithms.
You don't have to go build
a motion sensor algorithm.
a temperature algorithm.
You can participate
in the Nest home,
and we'll give you
that information.
So we got a quick look at
the Works with Nest API.
You saw a little bit
of tools that we have.
And you're going to get started
with a realtime stream, right?
Either Firebase
or REST Streaming.
When building a product,
consider what else
that you could do
besides basic control,
especially with
connected products.
It's not just about remote
controlling something.
That's not a smart product.
That's a connected one.
And sign up for more
information on Nest Weave.
We'll have a lot more
for you later this year,
and if you sign
up on our website,
we can get a lot more
information going.
We're going to have some
Q&A in about a minute,
so if you guys
have any questions,
feel free to bring it up.
I'm assuming there's
going to be a few.
So thanks a lot for listening.
My name's Andrew.
You can find us on
developer.nest.com.
We have a Stack Overflow account
with a Nest-API tag, as well as
a GitHub account.
Ryan Seys on our developer
engineering group
just created a really awesome
REST Streaming example,
showing building
a quick dashboard
in your mobile browser.
And thank you.
So let's see if we
have any questions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think the big obvious
one is all day yesterday,
we were listening
about Brillo and Weave.
I know that Nest Weave is
different than the other Weave.
Are you guys talking
to each other at all?
ANDREW URMAN: Yeah.
Once in a while.
Just kidding.
We are constantly in
communication with each other.
As you might have heard
from the other ones,
we will share device schema.
We'll have a common
schema between each other.
But really, Nest Weave
is about the home.
All of our connectivity
methods are
about the home-- low-power
battery constrained devices
like context sensors
and motion sensors, that
need to run on really
small hardware.
And it's an application layer.
So it's fully cross-platform.
We didn't want to silo anybody
into one platform or not.
And one of the biggest points
is whether using Nest Weave
locally, it will look the
same in the cloud, as well.
So if you don't want to
adopt Nest Weave locally,
you could still
use our cloud APIs.
But where we're
focused on the home,
Google's focused on the world,
connected to everything.
And that's really
where we differ.
We kind of used Weave as
a broad connectivity word.
So that's kind of the main
difference between both of us.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because a lot of
the statements you
made today, the low
power, the connect local,
that's exactly what
we heard yesterday.
ANDREW URMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
the biggest thing
I heard just now that was
different from what I heard
then is you're
giving us some really
good-- the last part of-- you're
giving us some really good
analytics, some really
good decision-making, which
we sort of heard when we
were listening to Tensor Flow
yesterday.
So we're seeing a lot of
overlap between you guys,
and not getting a
lot of clear answers
about who we're supposed
to be listening to.
ANDREW URMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And if
you guys are, again,
if you guys are working
together at all.
ANDREW URMAN: We are working,
again, very closely together.
And we would like
to converge the two.
But right now, again,
we're focused on the home
and Google's focused
on the world.
But other than the
standard schema,
they're really different
connection types.
And we started as a purely
cross-platform play.
And we wanted to stay a
purely cross-platform play.
So being everything's
based on IPv6,
it might provide something
easier down the road.
But as a developer, if you
want to build a Nest Weave
product that connects
with the Nest ecosystem,
you're going to have
to use Nest Weave.
Yeah.
And, again, we'll
have a CodeLab right
after this for about an hour.
We have some of our great
engineers here as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you hear me?
ANDREW URMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What
about considerations
for user interface?
Any issues or thoughts?
ANDREW URMAN: Oh, tons.
As part of the certification,
we do a user interface review.
We do a US and UI review.
But it's not hard requirements.
For Nest Weave, we will
have hard requirements.
Things need to look
really simple to users
and be really easy to use.
So a device can be
connected to the network
and have all this
access to all this data,
but not be very easy
to use and simple.
So yes, we do have
considerations.
We don't have a requirement,
any information on requirements
right now, through.
AUDIENCE: And no
platform, or open source
for like UX designers yet.
I know things are heavily
geared towards developers,
but if you need designers.
ANDREW URMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
So everything being based
on this standard schema,
in the Nest app, everything
could look the same.
We're also excited
to hopefully open up
to developers to build their
own experiences within the Nest
app.
But it would be interesting to
build a community around the UX
and UI of the home, what's
good and what's bad.
That would be interesting.
I'd like to talk to you
about that a little more.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Sure, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
maybe this is taking
that question up a
little bit level to sort
of the ethnographic level.
Does Nest participate
in the public discussion
of what home life is,
again, from an ethnographic
descriptive point of view?
How often do North American
front doors open and close,
stuff like that.
ANDREW URMAN: No, we don't.
We don't in the sense where
it's about Nest user data.
We don't really
release user stats.
We don't like to use the users
kind of as-- yeah, what's that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just
mean scientifically.
ANDREW URMAN: Scientifically.
Unfortunately, we don't.
We sometimes work
with universities
on specific topics.
But not in this.
If you have anything in mind,
I'd love to kind of bounce
around.
I'd love to do a research
project with a university
or something.
All right.
I can't really see
anything, so earlier
when I asked if
anyone heard of Nest,
I really hope everyone
raised their hand because I
can't see anything.
All right.
If there's no other
questions, we'll
have a Code Lab, sorry, a Code
Review in our office hours
just across the hall.
Thank you.